hey guys my name's Samuel Leeds not a
property investor and a lot of people
say that I just got super lucky because
I bought my very first house and I
bought it and I we financed it the same
day I bought it I bought it below market
value we find that the same day pulled
all of my money out leaves the company
called mortgage Express and that meant
that it was a no money down deal now
then rented out room by room made a
thousand pan and profit that was my
first house people said I got lucky and
the reason they say that is because
shortly after I bought my first house
that way they brought in this rule which
is called or everyone calls it the new
six month rule now the new six month
rule is not that new in fact it's really
really really really old and what the
six month rule is is all mortgage
companies all lenders said from now on
if you want to buy a house and you want
to refinance the house you've got to
wait six months before you can refinance
a house and it kind of killed the
strategy at the time and I'm in bed one
saying the days of three houses are over
you know and that was it so maybe I did
get lucky however the people that make
the rules are the same people that make
money in property and something that the
media didn't really talk about too much
was when they changed the rules again
which they did more recently and I'm
just going to tell you guys about this
because for me I'm making a lot of money
off the back of this and normally people
really seem to know about this but they
actually change the rules again the last
year and the six-month rule now no
longer applies which means that you can
now buy a house and refinance it pulling
all of your money out and you don't have
to wait six months anymore to do that so
I mean there's there's quite a few
mortgage lenders that do this one of
them is Kent reliance also you want to
check out precise mortgages that's I've
done a recent deal with them and if
you're just completely confused about
what on earth I'm talking about then let
me just keep this really simple okay
if a bank said to you that they would
give you 100 percent of the money to buy
a house now as far as I've been in
property this has never happened
lenders don't say this but if a lender
did if they said to you hey I'll give
you a hundred percent of the money for
you to go buy a house and then rent that
house out and the the interest typical
back banks of what the interest that you
have to pay is around about three
percent as long as you can find a house
where the return is more than three
percent and if you can't you suck then
you're going to be making an infinite
return on investment and the bank's
funding the house but it's your house so
when the house goes up in value you
benefit not the bank you pay them three
percent anything above three percent
you'll keep an eye I mean just to put
this into perspective my house is give
me twenty percent return on investment
in some cases so if the bank said that I
think you would unless you're stupid you
would be able to go and buy an unlimited
amount of houses make an unlimited
amount of money and and and just wait
for the prices to go up with the houses
the problem is the banks don't say that
the banks say that they'll only lend you
typically 7080 percent so you've got to
cough up that initial twenty twenty five
percent deposit yourself and the reason
people don't buy property investments is
because they don't have that twenty
twenty five percent deposit because
let's say a house is 100 grand I mean
the average house is 200 grand but say
100 grand and you need 20 percent that's
still twenty thousand pound plus legal
fees so it's a substantial chunk of
money so what smart investors do instead
because they don't no one has unlimited
money so what they do is they buy a
house for a hundred grand they put down
their 20 grand but then what they do is
they add value to the house so they lift
the value of the house by fixing a
problem maybe fixing maybe there's no
kitchen and there's no sink and there's
no taps and it's a bit rubbish or maybe
there's a legal issue there's a flying
lease holder or a covenant on the
property that is keeping the price low
so they fix that problem and then they
force the value of the house up once the
value of the house has gone up what they
they then get a new mortgage a new
buy-to-let loan based on the new value
which means it's looked a lot higher so
70% of the new value is a hundred
percent of the original value which you
paid which means that you're buying a
house and then you're refinancing it and
you're pulling out a hundred percent of
the money that you put in which is
called recycling your money so you can
do that and then do that again and again
and again and again now that's what
smart investors do most investors think
you have to wait six months to refinance
you don't they scrap that rule so I just
I just went I just felt like a hat to
share this with you guys because so many
people think that I have to save deposit
to buy a house and then save again and
other people think that the six months
for all is still out there when it's not
as long as you add value to the house in
the meantime you can buy a house you can
add value to it and then the following
week you can pull your money out which
is just exciting so if you've got
questions around that comments thoughts
if you're going to do more videos about
different aspects to this strategy then
I would love to hear your thoughts below
so just drop a comment below let me know
exactly what you want to learn exactly
what questions you have there any
thoughts on this if you're going to do
this let me know and I'll tailor my
videos specifically to you so you can
succeed in your property journey on the
basis that when you go and succeed you
tell me because your success is my
oxygen first thank you so much for
watching that video I really feel what
you need to understand as an investor
what bridging finances so I've done a
video around bridging finance right here
check it out also if you'd like to spend
two days as a property investors crash
course tailoring your strategy and
actually finding live deals book on to
the crash course right here and don't
forget to subscribe over here